here are four quotes and one statement
after hearing them let us know if you
agree or disagree and why
ready
abortion is legal because babies can't
vote
no woman can call herself free who does
not control her own body
race and skin color are socially
constructed not biologically natural
if liberty means anything at all it
means the right to tell people what they
do not want to hear
and finally we are educators and the
world ain't round
to optimize for learning and retention
pause the video write how you agree or
disagree in the comments below and then
continue
[Music]
when you discuss a topic and everyone
agrees the conversation often dies out
quickly but when you disagree you're
putting yourself in opposition to what
was said you take risk and have skin in
the game
this can bring the discussion to a level
where everyone involved learns more
about the issue if we are going to
disagree we should be careful to do it
well
but what does that mean
in 2008 paul graham attempted to answer
this question by proposing a hierarchy
with seven stages of disagreement
ranging from weak to strong
the lowest level is name calling which
attacks the person and not what they say
if bob and jen say we are educators and
the world ain't round you may answer you
are idiots
second is the ad hominem attack which
questions the authority of someone
without addressing the argument
if they say we are educators and the
world ain't round you can respond you
may be educators but you certainly
aren't scientists
like name calling it's a weak form of
disagreement as it attacks them but not
what they say
third is responding to tone meaning to
criticize the style of language rather
than its content
if they say we are educators and the
world ain't round you can reply ain't is
bad english first learn to speak
properly
it is a weak form of disagreement as you
object to the tone and not the content
you're still not saying much
fourth is contradiction
now we get responses to what was said
rather than by whom or how
if they say
we are educators and the world ain't
round you can retort it is round
contradiction can have weight because
sometimes seeing the opposing case
stated explicitly is enough to get the
point across
but this is not always the case
the counter argument is a contradiction
with reasoning and the first form of
convincing disagreement
if they say we are educators and the
world ain't round you can answer i'm a
scientist and it isn't flat either
in fact from space it looks pretty round
when aimed squarely at the original
argument it can be convincing but often
two people who are arguing passionately
about something are actually talking
about two different things
the refutation is quoting someone and
explaining why they are mistaken
if they say we are educators and the
world ain't round you may respond when
you say that you are an educator and the
world ain't round you actually imply
that you have authority and that the
world is flat
videos from space a proof it's pretty
round
it's a convincing form of disagreement
it's also a rare form because it's more
work
refuting the central point is the most
powerful form of disagreement
prior to this level you have been
unclear or in the worst case
deliberately dishonest
if they say we are educators and the
world ain't round you can refute the
central point as such
your statement that the earth is not
round is technically right the earth
being closer to an ellipsoid
but by only sharing what the earth is
not without adding any clarification you
lead people to believe whatever fits
best with their own convictions provided
it is not that the earth is round
assuming educators are meant to help
people understand better this is in
direct contradiction with the idea of
you being an educator and thus makes
your statement an oxymoron
graham stated that there are three main
benefits of knowing forms of
disagreement
it helps us to evaluate what we read see
and hear
in particular it helps us spot
intellectually dishonest arguments from
speakers who use words eloquently
it makes conversations richer because
participants focus on the actual point
it makes us happier
lower levels of disagreement attack the
person which is mean
higher levels of disagreement attack the
idea which is easier to accept and
assimilate
most people don't really enjoy being
obnoxious they sometimes are because
they haven't found a better way to
express themselves
if moving up the disagreement hierarchy
makes people less mean it will probably
make many of them happier too
what are your thoughts do you agree or
disagree with graham
if you don't feel strongly about this
topic you'll probably disagree with one
of the other four statements we made at
the beginning
but can you refute the central point
we will now repeat them let us know how
you disagree with them in the comments
below
abortion is legal because babies can't
vote
no woman can call herself free who does
not control her own body
race and skin color are socially
constructed not biologically natural
if liberty means anything at all it
means the right to tell people what they
do not want to hear
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts
you